avant l'opération je t'ai toujours
refusé je faisais mon travail pareil
mais j'étais toujours fatigué madame
désilets avait jusqu'à tout récemment un
problème cardiaque grave inopérable une
valve qui laisse échapper du sein qui
déforme son coeur et qui ultime menace à
ses jours
quand un cardiologue te dit à l'endroit
c'est si vous continuez comme ça madame
vous allez mourir en mars dernier son
médecin lui propose nouvelle
intervention et pas n'importe laquelle
une première mondiale au lieu de la
proche classique ouvrir le patient le
brancher sur un coeur artificiel et
remplacer les pièces défaillantes
on tend une stratégie complètement
différente la procédure chirurgicale
visait à en gagner le coeur avec un peu
comme avec un bonne nylon ou avec un
appareillage qui tend à le contenir à
l'empêcher de dilater davantage voici
l'instrument qu'on a utilisées pour la
procédure il été conçue par une
entreprise américaine est modifié sur
les conseils de l'équipe du docteur
bouchard durant l'intervention réalisée
avec une simple décision
on les sert d'abord à l'extrémité du
coeur du patient
le chirurgien fait ensuite glissé le
fils est taillé sur mesure sur la
surface de l'organe
puis on y ajoute des ballonnets qui vont
servir un mois plus tard ajuster le
dispositif on laisse le tout des rires
de devenir adhérent myocarde donc à des
rancoeurs et dans un deuxième temps
quand tout est bien adhérents on va
venir gonfler de façon très très très
précises
juste à temps qu'on a ajusté la valve
parfaitement bien une fois en place le
dispositif permet à la valve défectueuse
de se refermer efficacement au coeur de
reprendre ses dimensions normales et aux
patients de retrouver son souffle
chacun commence tranquillement afin
d'échanger accusés afin d'être chaud
puis l'après-midi beige jeu comme les
vieilles scolaire selon dr bouchard
le dispositif pourrait éventuellement
rendre service à un grand nombre de
patients
la même situation que notre patient
c'est un énorme problématique
cardiologique donc on parle des millions
de patients en amérique du nord
présentement non traitées et non
traitées car trop malade ici normand
grondin radio-canada mauvaise